[Music]
wildlife control agent Steve d'amour and
his team have set a net to catch three
wild hogs that are tearing Mary and
Thomas Scott's lawn to shreds after a
long time waiting for the Hogs to appear
the agents patience is finally rewarded
the Hogs are too quick and the net
misses them completely actually pretty
good but what happened is we had a
tether there's a little more forcefully
respecting from the shot that should be
open out to right here or I'm standing
but it actually has closed and only
really happen to distance because when I
came to full expansion it bounced back
both work yeah
having failed to catch the hogs with the
net launcher Steve decides a new
approach is needed
and when the hogs head down to a length
that borders the property he thinks the
handheld nets could be the answer don't
have great eyesight but their hearing is
sharp so the agents approach as quietly
as possible
on three one two three go
[Music]
you open no matter in the woods
walk through the doorway right now
a hogs natural defense when threatened
is to run and they are capable of
reaching speeds of 30 miles per hour
with so many brutes raid the agents have
little chance of catching
[Music]
they put the moves on us and hit
crisscross and just didn't quite get in
that time around even a little biggest
faster than we are is the team are to
capture these hogs they'll have to go
back to the drawing board